[Applause]
[Music]
Argentina is a country famous for three
things
tango soccer and the economic crises all
those that last one might change sooner
rather than later
yes vivió anse again we are talking
about lithium or white gold all the new
oils and it's discussed such batteries
are made out of lithium is what power is
your smartphone your laptop and maybe
even your electric car as we said in
this other video Argentina is alongside
with Chile and Bolivia
one of these three countries that make
up this so called lithium triangle this
is an area where sixty to eighty percent
of the world's discovered lithium
reserves are concentrators from these
three countries Argentina is getting the
biggest attention by international
investors yes you heard that right of
the biggest hedge funds have their eyes
on this country and this is a big
surprise given the dodging Tina used to
be the boogeyman of finances the problem
Charles of economics and now well it's
growing into something of a rock star
[Music]
so today's question is well what
happened to this country which improved
their image in such a short time can
they really become the leader of the
lithium race and most important of all
can lithium turn Argentina into a new
Ally's Derby today we are going to
answer all of these questions but before
we get started let's take a look at the
history Argentina first in the last few
years Argentina become something of a
bogeyman for hedge funds under the
presidency of Cristina Fernandez de
Kirchner Argentina's government did
whatever they could to scare away any
foreign company who might want to invest
in the country Kabongo Satrangi rose
keoki dengan angeas ambience entre rejas
economic ozl picado delle speculation
when it comes to the mining and oil
industry Kirchner made an interesting
move in 2008 she passed a law against
the repatriation of capital this means
that if an Australian mining company
made profit by extracting oil or
minerals on Argentinian soil the
government wouldn't allow the company to
send that money back to Australia
Kercher's goal was to force these
foreign companies to keep the financial
benefits of their mining in the country
masa the last times you can imagine the
consequence of this law was that most of
the foreign companies simply stopped
doing business in the country at the end
of the day I mean why would they if it
was forbidden to enjoy those profits at
home but well this it was not enough the
real turning point for Argentina came in
the year 2012
[Music]
Argentina expropriate swipe ef-2 Repsol
revs all the largest oil company in
Spain in the year 1998 merged with
Argentine company of yef for many years
this brand was simply called Repsol ytf
but one day Cristina Fernandez de
Kirchner in a very Donald Trump s
fashion said well Argentina first
hashtag make Argentina great again
callosum press a key Stan a key I won't
want to suffer let's stay here even if
their shareholders are foreigners are
Argentinian companies and now you might
wonder well what happened next well of
course the reptile refused several
lawsuits with the government of
Argentina but this was not the worst
thing the biggest problem was that after
being nationalized Argentine ydf reduced
their oil production
[Music]
the oil production extends decline as
rig activity slows yeah yeah listen I
know you're thinking you're probably
thinking what's the connection between
oil production and being owned by
private companies or being owned by the
government I mean there are several
state-owned oil companies that work
really well for one example there is a
ram code this is the biggest dinosaur
juice producer and filled that is owned
by the Saudi government the problem here
is that both in the oil and the mining
industry you need high tech yeah
each company has different technologies
and patterns in other words when ydf
wants to drill those oil beds of bakker
water they needed to utilize a
complicated technology called fracking
and well there are only a few companies
in the world that have the machines and
the skills to do this kind of work this
is why it is so common the difference
oil companies create in joint venture to
exploit an oil bet when Repsol left
Argentina why do you have lost a
technology partner and this is why
people say that curtain afford against
those Spanish neoliberal and ended up
partnering with the American ones
Chevron y PF signed 1.5 billion dollar
shale oil deal but hold on just a second
because well this isn't the end of our
story the biggest issue here is what
happens when you take over a company
from one day to the other well what
happens is the rest of the businesses
are going to be afraid of you and good
luck trying to convince them to invest
in your country
[Music]
think about it let's imagine you have an
oil or a mining company would you really
dare set up a factory and a lot of
facilities in a place where the
government can just see all of that from
you I think not and this among other
factors is what explains why Argentina
today has such a big crisis but are now
Argentina has a president called
Mauricio Macri and well the times they
are a-changin
white gold rush in Argentina in December
2015 macaroni took his place in the pink
house the thing else is the Argentine
version of the white house only sort of
Liguria confounder country in the middle
of bankruptcy real inflation with higher
than 40 percent dollars were sold on the
black market and there was no company
willing to invest in the country and all
of this was despite them being one of
the wealthiest countries when it comes
to natural resources this is why since
the very first moment Macri is trying to
conduct a 180 degree shift compared to
what its predecessor Argentina's new
government scraps mining taxes in other
words Macri knows that lithium is a
peerless opportunity to repair the
accounting verse of course now no one
expects Argentina to become a new de by
overnight but this white gold isn't huge
windfall and that money could cover the
gaps of Argentina's budget without
raising taxes and without cutting cost
and well this explains laws like this
one Argentina signs mining deal to unify
regulations attract investment in other
words from now on mining multinationals
have an open door to the country and
unlike what happens with the Kirchner
era these foreign companies can do
whatever they want with their profits
this is happening it because Macri has
removed the anti riparian law and if
this is not enough legislation has been
put in effect which unifies mining
regulations all across the country this
means that the rules are the same no
matter where the lithium bed is further
the mining companies will not have to
pay any special mining tax any more
industry heavyweights albemarle a quart
so clinica a manera de chile SI aromat
SI and jung SI khamphaeng listen company
are among groups looking at expanding or
building new lithium operations in
Argentina
supposed to hold on for just a second
because well things they are not quite
as great as they seem look listen is a
great opportunity for Argentina but as
you know having natural resources does
not mean your country is necessarily
wealthy many Argentinian fear what they
would call a new potosi this means that
they fear that their country would
become flooded with foreign companies
that take the resources and leave
without bringing any money into
Argentina so the question now becomes
well what can Argentina do to avoid such
a catastrophe a real chance of Argentina
as we said in a previous video the real
business of lithium is not lithium
itself but the added value products you
can manufacture with it
[Music]
at the time when we recorded this video
a metric ton of lithium had a market
price of $9,000 nevertheless if we take
that raw material and we turn it into
mobile phone batteries we could get an
income of between 1.5 and 5 million
dollars of course this is a very rough
estimation but it does help us
understand something important but hold
on just a moment because this is still
not as simple as it looks
most of the lithium battery factories
are in countries like the United States
Germany or of course China these three
countries have world-class network of
small companies that provide services
and components to the big manufacturing
plant we're talking about logistics
semiconductors and so on all of these
things make the manufacturing process
cheaper and more efficient but not only
that this network effect is what
attracts the best engineers and skilled
professionals to these countries this is
a central if you want to create a
high-tech industry in a country
I mean look good luck trying to convince
a woman who lives in San Francisco and
makes a six-figure salary to move to
Rosario Argentina to work in a factory
as you can imagine that's pretty much
impossible so now you might be wondering
what can we do to industrialize his
country well the first thing we have to
keep in mind is that Silicon Valley it
was not created in a day nevertheless
Argentina have a great advantage over
California they can make easy money by
selling raw lithium of course this money
can be used by the government to simply
boost their earnings but it is also a
good opportunity to invest in
universities that will train those
workers that might start those small
companies that are needed in order to
get the big factories up and running
services the government can also Co
finance brand new businesses this is
actually the formula that helps Israel
become a technological capital as well
so far it seems that Macri is committed
to working this way we have learned we
have understand that in addition to our
talents our huge natural resources we
have to add constantly you have to add
rule of law to be predictable
[Music]
but wait a minute because there are some
dark clouds on the horizon all these
opportunities Argentina has will
disappear if McCree or whoever follows
him falls back into the temptation of
destroying the rule of law and going
back to ultra-nationalism which could
scare away foreigners as it has in many
other countries and it seems the
Cristina Fernandez de Kirchner wants to
run the office again in a simple people
not asking you to vote for me ok but
then I locate I am not asking you to
vote for the people behind me I am
asking you to vote for yourself so well
now it's your turn
do you think Argentina could restore the
rule of Lorentz become a wealthy country
thanks to lithium nor are we going to
see a new nationalist backlash and a
brand new economic crisis well you can
leave your answer in the comment section
below and just before you go today I got
an important request from you you might
have noticed that we rather like using
rock music in our videos and we'd love
to hear from anyone who has a band and
thinks that their music could be a good
fit for us we will of course give credit
to any music that we do use in a video
if you are interested in this do drop us
an email that's info at visual politics
dot net also do not forget to check out
our friends at the rican to the media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that are not mine and if you
liked this video give it a thumbs up and
subscribe and as always I'll see you
next time and if you want to learn more
about politics and here even more of my
lovely voice you can join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider mediacom slash podcast see
you there
[Music]